so today I'm going to tell you about how
the Fibonacci sequence appears in the
medal round set hopefully your mind will
be blown
so the Fibonacci sequence the rule is
that you take the previous two numbers
and you add them together to get the
next right so we started with 1 1 their
sum is 2 the next number will be the sum
of 1 & 2 which is 3 the sum of 2 & 3 is
5 the sum of 3 & 5 is 8 I'll do one more
and then you can continue on easy easy
right and this occurs everywhere that
has interesting connections to things in
nature and all of that but I just want
to show you where it appears on the
Mandelbrot set so slightly less easy so
the Mandelbrot set is a special object
inside of the complex plane so the plane
of complex numbers and the way you cook
this thing up is by considering a
certain type of dynamical system so if
you give me a complex number C so here's
a picture of the complex plane so these
are the real numbers and these are the
real numbers x I which is that square
root of -1 if you give me a complex
number C it's in the Mandelbrot set if
when you take the function Z squared
plus C and you look at what happens to 0
when you plug it into this function
repeatedly if that number doesn't get
large then C is in the Mandelbrot set so
I know that sounds sort of complicated
but just let me do an example Rach so if
you look at C equals minus 1 right then
you look at the function Zed squared
minus 1 you plug in the number 0 0 if
you plug it into this function gives you
minus 1 minus 1 if you plug it into this
function gives you 1 minus 1 which is 0
again and so you're just gonna repeat
this pattern and so this number doesn't
get large no matter how far out we go
and so this number is in the Mandelbrot
set it's about right here so for each
complex number you make this decision
based on what happens to 0 under
iteration so it looks something like
this so there's this big piece in the
middle all this interior is included by
the way and a little disc around minus 1
and there's some more pieces coming off
of here and some kind of funny tenderly
stuff goes on out here and a few more
pieces this way another heart-shaped
piece mathematicians love this thing
even non-math
love this thing that maybe for different
reasons all right so where is the
Fibonacci sequence I mean first of all
this thing has nothing to do with whole
numbers an addition and arithmetic and
the kinds of things that you think about
with Fibonacci which is why it's weird
that you can see it in here but so let
me show you how to find it I didn't draw
too many of them but there's a bunch of
these little components coming off of
this main piece they're called the
hyperbolic components but let's not get
into that too these components I'm going
to assign a number and that number is
going to be the number of branches that
come off the sort of tenderly bit which
is called an antenna so like here if
this component there's this part where
we have these tendrils and there's three
different directions you can go in the
antenna and so this component will have
number three and similarly over here it
actually turns out there's only two
directions you can go in that antenna so
this is component number two now if we
look for the next biggest one the
largest component between the two and
the three component I've drawn it here I
haven't drawn the tendrils but I'll try
it turns out that there's exactly five
directions that you can go from that
antenna and the next biggest between
these two if you draw the antenna I'm
not sure I can fit it in here since I
think you already know what the answer
will be is eight so if you go through
the Mandelbrot set and you start with
these two components the two and the
three components and you look between
them for the next biggest component the
next biggest one will be the next
Fibonacci number so I want to explain
why explain at least part of why I have
I bet I called this big piece the main
component it's called the main cardioid
it's number is one actually that's a
really good question but it's not so
obvious to see from antennas so so the
main cardioid here number one it turns
out that there's a very natural way to
stretch this thing back into a disk
which is something we understand really
well right so this is always useful in
sort of geometry of that kind of study
if you can change something just a
little bit and get back to something you
understand
really well so there's a natural way to
view this thing just by some stretch so
this disk maps under this stretch to a
cardioid and I want to look at what
happens to first of all my center point
it turns out goes to zero this ray will
map to this ray this ray is I guess zero
of the way around the circle right if we
go halfway around the circle it maps to
this line inside the main cardioid if we
go say a third of the way around the
circle it maps to a kind of a funny
curve inside the main cardioid and
staying for two thirds and so on so you
can track what happens to these Ray's
under this stretch and here's the thing
is that the place where the Rays end up
in the main cardioid are exactly the
places where it connects to these
components so here is the connection to
the two component and here is a
connection to that top three component
and that bottom three component we have
a five component up here in the middle
right side so there must be some five
ray which lands there and in fact there
is it turns out that that's the two
fifths of the way around the circle ray
and the point is that under this
stretching map the number of antennae
the number we assigned to each of these
components is the denominator of the
fraction that tells you how far around
the circle you went this question of
what's the largest component between any
two other components turns into this
totally separate question of what's the
fraction with the smallest denominator
between these two fractions why is the
five component at two fifths and not one
fifth or three fifths what so the one
that I drew is between one-third and
one-half and so that's the two fifths
but there are five components at 1/5 3/5
and 4/5 you're totally right so yep so
works every time with the denominators
but the point is that you can read off
these numbers in two different ways
right the antennas or the denominators
of the fraction for the way around the
circle so we're closing in on Fibonacci
so I said that okay we changed this
question completely to a question of
what's the fraction with the smallest
denominator between two fractions
one-third which is less than some four
action which is less than 1/2 and the
question is I want a small denominator
fraction or how small can it be well it
can't be 4 right because 2 over 4 is the
same as 1/2 and 1/4 is too small but it
can be 5 because 2/5 really is between
these two numbers
okay so two fifths is the answer here
now what if we were to do the next one
the next one was asking between the
three and the five components right so
we want a number that's between 1/3 and
2/5 that has the smallest possible
denominator and again you can check six
and seven aren't going to do it it turns
out that the answer is 3/8 and in
general the crazy thing is that if your
fractions are close enough together the
way to find one between them that has
the smallest denominator is just by
taking the median or the fairy sum or as
some people refer to it freshmen sum
because you get it by adding together
the numerators and adding together the
denominators well because I think it's
mean actually I mean maybe a
kindergarten son is that better that's
right that's right it is a legitimate
thing I can tell you why it's bad right
so why is it a bad way to add fractions
because it matters how you represent
your fractions so if you try and add 1/3
to 1/2 this way you'll get something
different than if you add 1/3 to 2/4
right so it's not so good but it works
for this it works for this right so 1/2
here's the symbol usually use for
medians the mediant of these two
fractions is just two-fifths the mediant
of these two fractions is 3/8 and so on
so where is Fibonacci Fibonacci is
because look at the fractions I started
with I started with the first two
elements of the Fibonacci sequence and
the third and fourth elements of the
Fibonacci sequence and the way I get the
next thing is by adding the other two
together and so it's exactly the rule
which defines the Fibonacci sequence
coming up in these fractions coming up
in their medians
and so coming up in the Mandelbrot set
[Music]
if you'd like to better understand the
Mandelbrot set and I mean really
understand it
then why not check out this look it's a
Mandelbrot set quiz and a Julia set quiz
as well we've covered the Julia set
before they're from brilliant a problem
solving website that lets you go further
into the world of math and science by
not just watching stuff but doing stuff
there's a lot to like about these
curated sequences but what I like is
that they guide you through step by step
help you understand but it's not all
about scoring your work or making you
feel silly I mean you can look up the
solutions you can look up hints they
help you along the way
and they also help you understand just
how beautiful mathematics can be it
really made an impression on me I really
feel like these people know what they're
doing they've made a good thing to check
it out go to brilliant org slash
numberphile I'll put that down in the
description you can sign up for free but
the first 233 people who do that's a
Fibonacci number will get 20% of an
annual premium subscription